quatre plaintes de lager s'il vous plaît
qu'on a de la doua de l'évêque on sait
où ils avoueraient au moins ce sont des
boulets qui arrive de l'autre
j'ai une petite idée de l'endroit où il
pourrait le four est maintenant temps et
là vous et messieurs on est le
fisherman's tortueux consignes sega dès
demain chez duke management c'est quoi
le genre de musique qu'ils ont chanté
c'est du rock and ride et 1757 juin la
diarrhée j'aimerais beaucoup vous
représentez vous avez un son unique et
on pense que vous pouvez intéresser un
label deux premiers revers
[Rires]
j'ai besoin d'une chambre
service réveil de boue attendez moi
ce dépenserait son argent pour entendre
chanter dix pêcheurs ce qu'il y a un
moral au fond de chacun de nous si
jamais on accepte de vous prendre comme
manager vous devrez nous connaître
[Musique]
vous moquer de nous vous avez ma parole
et on est vraiment fort
lequel des deux
j'ai réussi à convaincre les dix
pêcheurs de saigner améliore
j'espère que leurs efforts seront
récompensés comme
[Musique]
envie d'être le mec qui est passé à côté
des buts à
cela
soit
m
les réservoirs dot je suis beugnot
[Musique]
gros bétail
oh